[Music]
you're done with this film I don't think
you'd begun work yet on the next one you
have some spare time I'm just curious as
a friend I'm just curious to know what
do you do in your downtime you know when
I have a lot of downtime you know I love
animals and my family does and I
actually work with dogs we actually
actually train dogs
you really do it's just kind of a
release for me it's very gratifying work
with a lot of dogs who have behavioral
issues and it's a great way to give them
confidence you work with the owners and
that sort of thing so you're saying that
you actually get that you work with the
dogs and I mean are you good at can you
train them to do things I we do a whole
obstacle course thing and we've actually
brought some of the dogs here and
tonight and I would love to kind of put
them through their paces if it's already
show us what it is you can do this is I
would love to see
let me just explain this is a sight of
you I did not know about means it's it's
really free kind of frees your mind but
what's gonna happen is we're gonna have
the dogs they'll go one at a time
they'll go up the the ladder here then
through the the the wheel of the slalom
yeah through the tunnel and the chute
across the tightrope and then up the
teeter-totter and down the other side
and this is absolutely the most
impressive thing I this is fantastic I
am so proud of these animals they when I
first had them they couldn't do any of
this and now it's well you'll just see
so oh we could all right let's let's
bring them out and we'll do your thing
this is fantastic
let's go okay okay okay
soon-ja
[Applause]
[Applause]
hey I'll lure you with a spoon get back
here just go up the thing go up the
thing you get back I'm gonna ship you
off to a Mexican citizen over here and
you do you do the thing that we worked
on okay you go through you go through
here because you idiots
[Applause]
take just take it easy go oh just go up
the sag it's so easy just take it easy
so easy okay well okay they didn't
really do it they didn't really do
anything that you said they were gonna
do you just stood there look good
clicker doesn't seem to do much of
anything well all right well I that's
the movie nice that was terrible yeah
the movies Casa de mi padre i believe
yeah and thank you for this
demonstration on the him a chance on the
wire give me a chance look
well
I don't know what else to say Will
Ferrel ladies and gentlemen we'll be
right back